this is exciting we're in Calgary for
the Bud Light House party this is pretty
spectacular because an intimate setting
yeah do you prefer an intimate setting
compared to being out there on stage
with thousands of people yep
it depends on what I've been doing the
most of lately yeah so if I've been out
in that environment a lot I really enjoy
coming back down to I'm like this but if
we've been doing a lot of intimate set
shows and we get to do the bigger shows
for a little while it's always
refreshing so I like to do both kind of
nice to see people close up - yeah yeah
I kind of I started and was inspired to
become a songwriter and start writing
songs in because of little songwriter
nights in Nashville so like settings
like this for young and up-and-coming
songwriters are where you kind of get
your chops and test out songs so that's
where I guess got comfortable in the
first place sitting in front of people
and they're you singing buddy like open
back road and I mean that must have been
an adrenalin just to see how people
react into it yeah it was pretty amazing
um it's funny you try to anticipate like
which songs are gonna react the best
when you get out on the road and I'm
learning - I've known I've getting to
know what my audience I feel like more
and more but I didn't know how people
were gonna react to that one I was just
blown away by the response we got yeah
so yeah it's one of the most fun songs
to play it's a it's a great song
congratulations it's just this light and
fun and in a live environment with our
fans I'm learning that they like that
side of what we do a lot so and I enjoy
it too so you know a lot of artists go
on that ride when they had that success
they take it and own it but you kind of
stepped back from it mm-hmm why is that
it just for a couple years there it was
pretty intense and it was a drastic
change of pace and a drastic lifestyle
shift for me as somebody who had just
been not casually writing songs I was
working hard in Nashville but I had a
routine and I'd kind of settled into
Nashville and it was my it was home and
and taking off on the bus and doing
things like this interviewing the
interviews and talking about myself and
my music it was it was a little bit it
was a lot for a couple years so I kind
of
step back I got married as well that was
a big part of yeah congratulations but I
got to a point where I really didn't
feel like I could I was eating I was
smelling the roses happening so fast so
I step back and kind of digested it all
and kind of processed everything that
had happened more than anything made a
conscious effort to think about how one
of the next few years to go and how I
want to experience I was late 20s going
into my third he's wanted to experience
how I wanted to experience my thirties
I'm like how I want to approach music
going forward so I needed to think about
it because my head was kind of spinning
so I took a step back to think about
that and kind of reboot and I'm excited
to get back out now and that's that's
pretty amazing Sam if you really think
about it you have self-awareness you
understand I think he used the word
moral template as well right and what's
important to you you knew that that's
your philosophy background it's
impressive that you can do something
like that like how do you get your mind
in that position knowing this is what I
want right now
and this is what I have to hold off for
now yeah I think I was for me it helped
a lot to be a little older when I found
success I know you know a lot of kids
get into it 17 18 19 20 21 and I can't
even imagine getting into the world that
I got into when I was a little older at
that age so it helps a lot to know who I
was who I wanted to be and and I think
you know you just gives you a little
more self-awareness so I had a little
more that by the time I got into this
[Laughter]
but you know things like things like
getting married for instance movies that
that's that was a big decision yeah
because you know this the lifestyle at
that time I had to decide like is this
something is this environment as this
lifestyle is this career a place where a
marriage can thrive and kids and all
those sorts of things so I had to stop
thinking about that and I had to make a
big decision because going forward it
was like I'm either going on in or I'm
gonna take a step back and and get
married and get my footing there before
getting back into this and that's kind
of what I decided to do do you love
being married I do yeah
it's um it's been it's been great I've
been married for two years now a little
over two years and that was there's been
a learning curve
yes the other thing about being a little
older is you've developed all your
selfish habits your world kind of
revolves around you and you have to that
gets exposed for to quit when you get
married yeah I'm learning I think I'm a
lot better husband now than I was when I
first first got married oh did you hear
that everyone all the guys you gotta
work on that but you and you you again
self-awareness you know this in that so
yeah I mean you come from a big family
as well is that something you want in
your own life yeah it is I have two
younger brothers and lots of cousins and
holidays and just having a big family to
be around on special occasions was
really important to me and those
relationships are still strong and all
of those individuals poured so much love
and to me and my life and supported me
and all the things all my all the things
I got into growing up and we're a big
part of my ability to be successful in
this music career so I want to be able
to provide that for the young people
that I bring into the world so yeah I'd
like to have a big family and luckily my
brothers will two little boys or girls
around yeah it's funny you say success
and do you like any aspect of Fame I
have my qualms with the way like you
know the way Fame is celebrated in pop
culture like and I'm I think about that
a lot where I want to stand how much I
want to contribute to the elements to
the parts of it that maybe aren't as
healthy and how much I want to just be
aware of what the right thing to do
under the right circumstances is and
it's it's you know it's a learning
process I'm still trying to figure out
but I never wanted to come across as
ungrateful because I am you know I'm
super grateful to have people who think
enough of me and our music to you know
spend their hard-earned money and come
out and spend their time supporting us
because they've they've changed my life
that giving me a future with my wife in
my family so
I'm really grateful so I never want it
to come across my my hesitancy to be in
the spotlight to come across this
ungratefulness I love that yeah and
being grateful you've been writing a lot
of music I understand yeah you have a
lot out there are you now recording in
the studio I'm working on your next
album and how's that going for you yes
it is for a couple years I was I was
riding trying to figure out what this
would write what to do next and I was a
little bit all over the place
it's hard for me to focus and then about
a year ago I decided okay over the next
12 months I'm gonna write a record and
whatever comes of it I'll put out and
that has come and gone actually as of
September as of the first of this month
yeah that would have been when I just
said that a year ago so yeah we've gone
in and recorded we've been in the studio
this week we recorded four songs I've
got several more to record and I plan on
turning it in first of the year but
we'll have a single out before the end
of this year so and what's the vibe like
I mean you're known for pop you're known
for a little bit of R&B it's just more
pulling back towards country though
there are some songs like the body like
a backyard song and that character was
sort of in my phone my first record to
in song my house party you know
sometimes I'll take it way too serious
and when I and then I'll just completely
like slingshot to the other side which
is where songs like house party and body
like a backer come from so there are
more of that there is more of that light
hearted sentiment on some songs and then
there are some reflective songs that
balance those songs out so hopefully we
can get the whole whole thing in there
talking about reflective music what has
inspired this album like you were
talking about your album five years ago
was inspired by air and out ye thought
and you've been on this journey now so
what inspired your new music I got to a
point where I was writing a lot by
myself early on in my career as a
songwriter I did a lot of co-writing and
I had two or three guys four guys that I
wrote with a lot and I got to where I
was writing by myself and I realized how
much of my inspiration comes from and
came from other individuals who
collaborate with I get in a room with a
producer who's making beats and music
and giving me inspiration as opposed to
me just sitting at home with a guitar
I was struggling for a little while by
myself trying to coming up with ideas so
I got back with some of my the guys I
wrote the first record wid and just
hearing them speak having conversations
with him in the room and and they'll
have ideas or they'll play me something
they're working on and it's just
immediately the inspiration comes back
you